well joe derosa's walking in
joe derosa of course you know not only
is a stand-up comic not only as a
podcast host but he is the proprietor of
joey rose's at 174 rivington street here
in new york city the
sandwich spot once again
joe enters the studio
with no
say what's in your bag
stuff i need for later for myself why
don't you ever bring sandwich psychotic
like troy brought donuts yesterday he's
coming back from florida and it's not
even his donut place so you you know
that um
to get donuts
you could just
go anywhere and get them on the way i
mean you literally make it to your
restaurant right yeah you're pronouncing
that we're not open till 12.
it's your choice and the breads
so you so you want me to open an extra
four hours early
you could just go in you don't have to
wait until you should just you have the
key well the bread's not ready usually
till about 10 30. you can get a couple
of loaves all right so you want me to
wake up even earlier go make sandwiches
to promote your thing it's it's if we
had chick-fil-a in here to be like it's
chick-fil-a day and then people would
come in with the chick-fil-a and even
though they wouldn't sit there and go
like you understand
these are on the lunch menu that's right
it's the morning right you don't get
that the multi-million dollar
conglomerate you're it's on rivington
street right and that's the that's the
point we're making because they're a
conglomerate they have advertising and
they have all that stuff you don't have
that stuff you just have kind of you and
word of mouth so because you're a
smaller
store like when you of course you would
go in and make a couple of we would only
have little pieces of them you can make
them how about your sandwiches these are
great and see how long that would take
me do you have any idea how long that's
going
we are we're de niro and casino right
now equal number of blueberries why
would a sandwich platter take you a long
time yeah every meat has to be sliced
fresh
everything just i don't make the
sandwiches in the kitchen
we have a guy that does that we have two
guys to do it i seen you in the kitchen
when we went to the original joey roses
i seen you in the kitchen times were
tough
i know that you know what you're doing
in there yeah i know how to do it yep
it's a question of do i want to do it
that's the that's the truth
but i can't
you could come down to the restaurant
but now you're putting the onus on jim
yeah i don't need to promote it no no
you don't need to but i want to but i
want thank you you should bring a
sandwich in that we could even split i
wouldn't even eat much
you just want a bite yeah why don't you
just come down and enjoy a sandwich it's
psychotic he's literally literally
come to the plate no because you get him
to come to the place by giving him
like i want to promote your thing and
when you go on a show
like we would we would be talking about
it and and then snacking on it and
saying oh great like it's like when
andrew yang came in right yeah he was
like i'm here to promote my new book
right you guys should have gone to the
bookstore to buy one
and we'd be like what are you talking
about
we don't have either because you didn't
bring us anything so you want me to
bring sandwiches a sandwich made on
thank you troy you want me to bring you
sandwiches made on day old bread
that i would have to get up an extra two
hours earlier to go to the shop and make
for you i think it would be okay if you
made the sandwiches last night and
brought them in this morning it was i
was putting them in a plastic i swear to
god i was at the shop last night and i
was gonna i was like maybe i should just
make them today i didn't want to bring
you like a day old thing i get up early
every day comics show i understand it
but i get up early every day like you i
have to get up early for this
yeah but thousands of years exactly
because you get up early you get paid
thousands of dollars jim i'm gonna talk
to somebody right but you're that's
exactly it it's a money thing so to
promote your restaurant would be a
financial thing like that that's
jim is right on now you're kind of
making my point i wake up because i get
paid to be here and you're promoting a
gig you want people to come to it of
course
it'd be like this it'd be like this it'd
be like this like if you were promoting
a comedy special yes and you're like i
want you guys to know
i won't be funny on your show because
the jokes are on the special no i'm not
bringing the jokes to the show so i was
promoting a club right date
i would come in here and i'd say here's
the information go to that club but you
would tell some jokes i would have
convinced you i wouldn't do bits we
don't no no no no no no no you don't do
bits but you do do jokes so you could be
like here's me telling jokes because if
you come on the show and you're not
funny people don't care where it is i
will say i will say that if i am in the
position where in a year from now i'm
explaining to investors what went wrong
yes i will say i promote terribly
give jim norton
no it's not about i'd like a bite too
it's not about giving jim norton a
sandwich because i know it's it's about
if you if you're promoting something you
you would bring it like it's crazy i
can't even wrap my head around it i
can't wrap my head it'll be like this
i did books and you know books are
different because you have to get up
earlier but i would love books that's
entirely different you don't have to go
in and make the book in the morning you
don't have to go to the printing press
preferably to make the print but that's
part of that's part of promoting it so
let me ask you this if you had a book
out right i would do that if i had if
you had a book out wait wait let me say
if you get a book out you're promoting
the book
the printing press goes like this jimmy
we're not gonna have books ready until
the morning up you go what time they're
like i don't know 6 a.m you go if i go
to the printing press at 6 a.m and get
the book before the radio appearance
will you give me the book and they said
yes oh sure would you go and get the
books i would have done that of course
and it's also like this the the example
wouldn't be printing press the example
would be doing a book signing because
you don't get paid for book signings you
have to give up a night of work to do it
all it does is further your book and
promote your book do anything you have
to go somewhere you can get on a plane
and flew to cleveland for no money you
just sit and you you take by the way by
the way do you think i'm not bringing
the sandwiches to other places
at a timely fashion i bring the
sandwiches anyway and by the way i mean
joe you're saying we're doing all kinds
of promotions this is the only show
that's very promotional that's very
insulting yes and by the way the
sandwiches are incredible don't get me
wrong sandwiches are great for most
people i don't know but
your defense of like jim you don't have
to do anything for a signing i just like
it's a psychotic it's a sandwich it's
not a dinner and you have to get up a
little bit earlier it's not hours of
preparation yeah okay and it's also not
if you say don't do anything for signing
i literally flew to west palm i flew to
cleveland and i'm not getting paid for
that so you're getting on a
[Laughter]
i mean that's part of what promotion is
yeah
i go all over the place to promote throw
some cold cuts on brad you know what i
mean i don't i promote okay dan and i
thought he started criticizing me dave
in san diego
[Laughter]
hey
it basically comes down to uh joe's just
being selfish and lazy are you being
selfish and lazy joe i didn't think it
was that far yeah dan what do you do for
a living my friend
i'm an engineer
yeah dan dan dan let's let's tech let's
tack two other jobs on top of engineer
and then ask you to get up
four hours earlier than you usually do
for your engineering job and then tack
another two hours onto that when you
have to do your other three jobs that
day and then talk to them that's a long
day dan go get up get up get up at 4 00
a.m instead of 8 a.m to go weld and then
tell me but if you're building another
business you're doing it
okay okay then get up at one it then get
up at 1am but you're doing thank you
what are we talking about i'm talking
about to build your business not not
because we want a sandwich this is no
it's not because you want to build the
business yeah it's like i've we've had
many people over the years come in and
promote this isn't a hunger thing no
okay we've had a lot of people come in
and you're genuinely upset about this no
i'm be fine i'm not mad at you i don't
care i'm not i'm not i would only have a
bite or two of it anyways i'm dieting
it's not about that it's
your lack of business
i'm befuddled by i have listen to me you
have bad business actually
i
i'm stunned my business all the time
like imagine if it was like using to
promote taste buds and i was like what
do you like better like uh like doritos
or fritos and he was like i don't have
preference this is terrible
like he's like i don't have a preference
no terrible example i didn't want to
bring you guys a substandard product the
bread is not done until 10 30 a.m every
day i didn't want to bring you day-old
bread as i said i was in the shop last
night i considered bringing you
sandwiches that were made last night i
did not think that was a good look no so
it didn't happen you have a quality
you're like steve jobs i don't
understand what else i could have done
aside from wake up and make a sandwich
make a sandwich because it's not baked
yet but you could have come in and said
look this is from yesterday but the
bread's not ready in the morning that's
gross you
that's like saying all of this is just
an excuse because you didn't want to
make these sandwiches
i know that there's no i like that's
like saying that's like saying i'm going
to play a clip for my new special sorry
guys i shot it on my computer screen
with my iphone the audio is not great is
it that much of a difference no here's
the difference if if all of a sudden if
all of a sudden they said hey you were
gonna send us a clip for your special
and you said yeah but i didn't feel like
stop at home and actually put it into an
email no
you're ignoring the key factor here the
bread is not done until ten times but
i'm not i agree with you i like i'm sure
that that's true that's true and i'm
sure that's true and i'm sure yeah i
believe you and i know that that's you
but part of the greatness of the
sandwich to me is that we bake our bread
fresh daily and when you when it goes
past a day it's not fresh but we but
that's not why you didn't bring one
sure it is i don't believe you you don't
no
you think it's because he just didn't
want to get up yes i understand
pay my staff to come in two hours
earlier to do all these things all right
eddie says i'm being hard on you eddie
and arkansas thank you eddie let's do it
you guys are being really hard on well
i'm not mad at joe i just
why wouldn't being hard on him we're
trying to give him advice
his shoulders
oh okay
it wasn't a true defensive joke it's a
shoulder joke
jim's man cause he didn't get a free
sandwich okay joe i feel like you're not
avoiding this yeah this is hard
yeah i just i need to promote something
what sandwich would you have i don't
even know what they are you would just
love to have i mean it would have been
smart to bring in a sample plan we would
have given them out to the staff dave
remember remember that sandwich place uh
leonies
yeah
i
yes you might you know why you remember
them because they used to bring stuff in
they're delicious we used to do buffets
in the morning and again i'm not saying
we need to do all that that's a bit much
but you know what they even named one
after me and he named one after you yeah
i promise you douche and a fruit
i promise you this you know i like your
place by the way if you want to set up a
day far and
a little farther in advance than three
days notice where you want me to have my
staff go in early do this and i'll bring
a platter and i will do that a thousand
percent
we have to specifically request the
platter yeah no i'm no i'm saying though
if you want to set it up where you go
hey guy dude we want to set this up like
two weeks out so we can come in then
fine i'll do that
when was joe booked travis i texted
roman last night to say are we still
good like are we on for tomorrow night
i'm not blaming wrong books last week i
mean the idea that roland has poor
communication yeah but i did something i
could go with i'm not blaming i'm not
being wrong but i didn't get my check-in
thing until 9 00 p.m last night i didn't
even know if this was definitely
happening so let's let's let's let's
just say your book last week huh you're
really like looking are you can you do
that and i said yeah and then
last night at nine o'clock i texted him
and said are we
i mean i believe
i do believe you in that respect we do
we do have our own holes in our
operations let's not let's make it sound
like there was bread and salami sliced
already and all i had to do was roll out
of bed make a sandwich and bring it in
here there's other factors going on i
thought you were pulling up joe's menu
that's a different sandwich of stuff all
right julie julian albany wants to
defend the joke
okay what's up uh julie
hey i've i've been a chef for many many
years and
there's nothing that hurts a chef's
heart more
than not being able to present something
in its finest form joe's heart is not
hurt yeah i know it is and that's not
the issue hold on no thank you
no because you already said you don't
want to wake up early
he said that to start yeah he did that
he said he doesn't make the sandwiches
you said look i thought we were a comedy
show so i wanted to just break balls for
a minute okay and i'm telling you the
real reason is that i can i didn't want
to bring you a substandard product julie
is 100 right let my defender speak
but she's avoiding something you said
she is avoiding something
go ahead
no no no the even the sandwiches
that are over a certain age like like i
wouldn't go get a meatball sub
and then bring it home to eat two hours
later that's because of the sauce and
especially since we we joked about this
last time we talked to joe last time and
go hey there's no sandwiches and this
game it takes we already did it
yeah it's almost like what you say
doesn't resonate with me yeah yeah well
jim has been very successful in business
as a promoter i'm saying purely from a
promotional standpoint like i would do
anything i will say this
[Music]
i'd say this i think maybe to promote
your radio show you guys should be
coming down to my shop a little more
meeting the people talking to them
handing out flyers about your radio show
you know what i tell people
by the way
joe if i'm not mistaken yes
i did broadcast from your your shop i
didn't i did a show from your shop yeah
you did you came down to the taste buds
see yeah so yeah that counts for jim
that we're reporting you guys
all right guys if anything this this uh
panty ringing situation is gonna
probably cause even more interest on the
part of others oh jim norton got his
little [ __ ] knickers
well julie i'm not listen hold on lazy
chef
she is a lady hold on lazy chef i'm not
i'm not lazy i'm not even i wouldn't
have even eaten much of the sandwich
because i'm dieting it's it's not about
me i'm just as a person who also
promotes i'm surprised about the
promotion protest too much or whatever
but but i'm big i'm being i'm being very
sincere about that like i'm not saying
like where's my [ __ ] i know you're
not i'm telling her she thinks i got my
panties in a bunch and julie i've gone
out and done a lot of promotion yeah i
wake up at [ __ ] early in the morning
and i do sets late at night but
but
the only thing i'm taking a little bit
of issue with umbridge is the
insinuation that i'm not doing a lot of
promotion for my shop
this is one tiny example i can only go
with our show and by the way this is
true
yeah
what i'm saying is i don't i'm not going
to bring you a substandard product
that's clear and if you want to do it i
will do it i just need to know a little
more in advance that we're going to do
it but you didn't say getting up early
you don't want to get up like i did
drinking balls i did uh i didn't say
that i wasn't offended by it but i think
now i think about that so you were like
i'm like you want me to get up even
earlier to come to do this [ __ ] show
it's like i'm joking around
i went uh i had uh new hampshire on
thursday had to drive five hours from
the set we've all done this drive five
hours do the gig and then drive two more
hours to boston because i had morning
press which i didn't want to do and i
had two shows that night so i had to
wake up an hour hours earlier than i
wanted to but it's not about part of it
it's not i know
but it's not about waiting i know oh god
all right it is interesting too only
because you mentioned that by the way it
is interesting
did you think he was kidding
[Laughter]
joe familiar derosa is the
co-host of taste buds with sal volcano
available every monday on youtube and
across all podcast platforms
you can visit joey rose's and tell him
if he's there or the chef or whoever
what a bunch of [ __ ] we are sample
the sandwiches for yourself it's what
we'll have to do as well uh joey rose's
you'll go to the spot it's open now
174 rivington street you can find all
the photos and everything at joey rose's
hard 8 on instagram and the website for
hours and ordering and all that is
joeyrosesnyc.com
joeyrosesnyc.com yeah and then all my
upcoming stand-up shows tickets and info
are available julie rose joe derosa
sorry joe derosa info
dot com